this is what I put in I needed a max
with media query that would set the
background color to red when the screen
was no larger than 400 pixels then I
needed another media query that set the
background color to blue when the screen
was no smaller than 600 pixels and then
finally I needed to set the background
color to green for screens between these
two breakpoints I went ahead and did
that by setting the background color to
green before these two media queries
this way the CSS cascade kicks in and
it's only applied this color here when
these two breakpoints are not of course
I easily could have put background color
green into a media query but well I
didn't need to and there it is blue
green and red that wasn't too difficult